- LIFE IS ALL ABOUT
MAKING CHOICES,
AND I HAD CHOSEN TO ATTEND
UPPER PENINSULA STATE,
BUT I WAS STARTING TO WONDER,
WOULD ANYBODY CHOOSE ME?
- HEY, MADISON.
- OH, HEY, ELLIOT.
- WHAT'S GOING ON?
- YOU REALLY LIKE FRUIT, HUH?
- OH, YEAH, I GUESS I JUST
TAKE 'EM BACK TO MY ROOM
FOR IN-BETWEEN MEAL SNACKS.
THAT WAY, I NEVER
HAVE TO PAY FOR FOOD.
- WOW, THAT'S REALLY SMART.
- YEAH, I'M ON THE FLEX-450
SEMESTER MEAL PLAN,
SO AS LONG AS I DON'T GO
OVER 17 MEALS A WEEK,
I AM GOLDEN.
- WHAT UP?
MIND IF I CUT?
I'M JUST GETTING CHIPS
USING ALL POINTS.
THE MEAL PLAN'S
KIND OF FOR SUCKERS.
DID YOU KNOW
THE PENINSULA PIT'S
TAKING POINTS
AT ALL THOSE RESTAURANTS NOW?
- REALLY?
- I DON'T KNOW,
WOULD YOU MAYBE WANT TO GO
CHECK IT OUT SOME FRIDAY NIGHT?
- WHAT--WHAT TIME?
- THAT'S THE BEAUTY OF POINTS,
WHENEVER WE WANT.
- OKAY.
- WELL,
I'LL SEE YOU THEN, RED.
- YOU WERE SAYING SOMETHING.
- I'LL SEE YOU LATER,
MADISON.
- ♪ TODAY I AM THANKFUL
♪ I PRAY TO BE THANKFUL
'CAUSE OF YOU ♪
- ♪ THANKFUL FOR EACH DAY
- ♪ GOD, 'CAUSE OF YOU ♪
- AND SO I STARTED
SPENDING POINTS,
HOPING TO RUN INTO THE GUY
WHO TOLD ME ABOUT THEM
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
LOGAN, IT'S SO FUNNY
SEEING YOU HERE.
SO THIS HAMBURGER
IS 300 POINTS.
HOW MUCH IS THAT IN DOLLARS?
- $3.
- WELL, HOW MUCH
DO THESE FRIES COST?
- 175 POINTS, RED.
- HOW MUCH IS THAT
IN DOLLARS?
-$1.75.
- HOW DO YOU KEEP IT ALL
STRAIGHT?
- MAYBE IT'D BE EASIER
IF I SHOWED YOU.
LET'S SAY THESE FRIES
WERE 111 POINTS.
YOU JUST HAVE TO MOVE
THE DECIMAL POINT.
YOU GET IT NOW?
- ♪ I COULD NEVER
WALK ON WATER ♪
♪ THE WAY YOU DID
AS THE BIBLE SAYS ♪
- THIS IS GREAT, HUH?
- YOU KNOW WHAT YOU SHOULD DO
IS THROW A PARTY.
WE COULD GO TO THE DEER DELI,
MAYBE PICK UP SOME NACHO CHIPS,
COLA, COUPLE MAGAZINES.
YOU CAN BUY ALL THAT
WITH POINTS.
♪ MM-HMM
♪